the day before I just checked with him
the time and the phone number Brockman
and then he responded by saying where
the red gingham dress it brings out the
vein in your forehead only a rathole
could come up with that text how are you
right I'm fine as any NFL team sign any
of Lori Loughlin skids yes I don't
believe so too soon right I don't
believe so
not too soon actually just happened
about an hour ago right yeah well you
know what hmm so faster world out there
now it is that the Russell Westbrook
thing went went like literally five
minutes after it happened in Utah I saw
it in the palm of my hand on my phone
what's your stance on what happened in
Utah last night right well I keep
waiting for the Jazz to do what seems to
me to be the obvious thing which is to
come out boldly and aggressively against
a fan and behavior like that because
there's a there's an example in England
over the weekend
it hasn't been brought up in a couple of
hours that this has gone on which is a
Birmingham fan ran on the field and
punched Aston Villa's
Jack Grealish during a game in the neck
from behind I saw that and it seems like
we're not that far away from that again
every once in a while and it's it's sort
of cyclical fans have decided that
they're not enough of the proceedings
and I get where you could get frustrated
because you're paying so much money to
get the experience that they're offering
you but you you throw that in you throw
an alcohol you throw in the idea that
fans are part of the home court
advantage and it doesn't take very long
to go from abusive language to a felony
well in that respect ray if I could just
jump in here because I'm sure there are
some fans that might be thinking this
hearing you say this or watching it that
the fan did did not appear to be drunk
and said he didn't say anything
wrong right well okay but at some point
there there's a line that's being nudged
really hard here and if there aren't
limits sort of just civil limits that
that you can obey whether you're drunk
or not then you're going to get a really
blurry line like the one we have here
and at that point you know I mean
Russell Westbrook's going to get fined
for this I mean we know that but you
know the Jazz have had more than a few
incidences of this and I don't know if
it's because the fans there feel like
they have to really make it difficult
for other teams to play there or whether
there's a more cultural component going
on but it seems to me that an
organization as progressive as utah's
has to be sort of a lot more aggressive
about this because this is not the first
time they're fans have been singled out
by players for for a language that
enrages if this was a first time
incident maybe you could say okay you
pull the fan aside and you say listen
that's not happening again or you can
either sit up in the last row of the
arena or you can just never come again
but this is you know this is not a first
time for Utah fans and at some point
you've got a draw line or the lines
going to get drawn for you by the cops
well what about the NBA drawing a line
and getting these fans further away from
me from the action I mean they're right
on top of it I mean just somebody who's
I'm sure spent many time on press row
rates it's all it's all right there yeah
and and it only serves to obviously it's
great for a kid or we all know Russ was
touched by a kid a couple weeks ago and
then and his initial reaction was
rightfully so he had no idea who's
touching him it seems like the players
are more touchy than
ever and and I'm wondering if this is
part of the powder keg for the lack of a
better phrase here well I mean the fans
have been right next to players for
decades the people who got moved away
from court proxies proximity was the
media because they were the obviously
the big problem
so yeah fan you know Kings can't charge
twenty five hundred dollars a ticket if
they move you back six feet or ten feet
or twelve feet I mean a warrior game I
mean there's nothing but high rollers on
that front row well you know if you
don't yeah if you don't have
wall-to-wall you know high rollers you
know then that second row is anybody who
can get something on the secondary
ticket market and that's where they
don't sort of have price controls so you
your end up taking your chances and
they're not giving that up there's too
much money for teams to make by having
their fans right there and so that's not
going to change what has to change is
teens tolerance for fans crossing that
line and it has to be visible so that
players see that something's being done
conversely russell westbrook doesn't
really get to threaten a woman unless
the woman it can be shown to have been
aggressively part of this and at that
point then you have another debate but i
think the legal the legal will obviously
take some money from from Westbrook and
westbrook will be will feel like okay
that's that's a price I'm gonna pay
because I'm going to keep doing this as
long as this keeps going on but at some
point somebody's not going to have that
sense of restraint somebody's going to
go in the stands and then and then what
have you gotten so I I think at some
point Utah's got to be more not only
aggressive but you know publicly
aggressive about dealing with this and
the NBA is going to have to come out and
I would suspect that Adam silver will do
that today because he shoes
party up on sort of serious issues that
come up for him and he's going to have
to make it clear that the line has
finally been hit we've we've reached the
third rail and the only thing that's
left after this is to watch people get
electrocuted ray Ratto joining us from
the Bay Area on the Rich Eisen show okay
you as being as close to the Warriors
campaign as as ever
how troublesome is this stretch right
now we've seen DeMarcus Cousins exposed
defensively we've seen the the
lip-reading incident involving Steve
Kerr about draymond Green and this is
what Kerr had to say yesterday when
talked about the lip-reading that we all
saw on Twitter the night before I beg to
differ with Raymond's approach
I don't know how somebody misconstrued
modern life everything's recorded
everything is filmed I've decided I'm
now gonna get a giant laminated board
with all my play calls and I'm gonna
turn in and Renetta from here on oh well
I love Steve Kerr in every way shape of
form ray he handled it with humor but
the bottom line is that at the very
center of all this that he does appear
to be tiring of draymond greens approach
how serious is this right now for a
warrior's championship run it's not that
serious but it does speak to an issue
that's been going on with this team for
at least a couple of years if not longer
which is that they seem to be
perpetually aggrieved more than most
teams by the officials to the point that
sometimes draymond will just get lost in
it and I think to a lesser extent
DeMarcus Cousins is also guilty of that
that there's if there's this sense that
part of draymond being draymond is
losing his mind about a call here and
there and as a result he doesn't get
benefit of the doubt anymore and so you
know they've worked him far closer to
the letter of the law than most players
and Steve Kerr has sort of tried to
laugh this off and front this off but
now it's starting to bother him and I
think it's bothering him because though
the Warriors sort of margin for beating
the hell out of other teams is narrowing
so now they're they're closer to the
kind of team that needs all the
advantages it can get and when you're on
the wrong side of the officials you lose
you lose one of those advantages I mean
they they led the league in technical
fouls in 2017 they led the league in
technical fouls 28 they're one behind
Oklahoma City in 2019 and they think
they've gotten a reputation with
officials
that they complain about way more than
they have business complaining about and
I think that you know when draymond is
goes off on those sort of momentary rage
tangents that sometimes he doesn't pull
back out of I think he starts losing you
know the thing that makes him good which
is you know sort of that aggression and
you know he gets he gets frustrated he
gets lost and I think that's what Kerr
was was that what is complaining about
because for the most part he likes
draymond Green he I mean draymond Green
is his kind of player because he was a
bit of an RA when he played - that's
where we're at now it's just the
Warriors are not playing well enough to
be able to indulge themselves you know
with you know this referees screwing me
or how do I get in you know
EDD Malloy's grill you know that at some
point you'd better be winning by a lot
if you want to win yeah I mean when you
say do we lose ray right there I think
we lost them right there just uh it's
just so you understand RA did not stand
for residents assistant
I think it's the the color of red and
the posterior you there still bring I am
here okay great I lost I never laugh
yeah that's very good all right but
you're right back there okay so so none
of this has to do at all with with
draymond and Durant back here in Los
Angeles that caused Raymont to be
suspended one game in I find it hard to
believe that that's totally wiped out
and that July 1st doesn't loom right now
I mean it's entirely possible though
that they are led pipe wielding
championship professionals who can maybe
box it up for the best they can to make
one last run here or another run and
none of that's lingering at all I don't
think so because it would have shown
itself in other areas and you know the
weird thing about the Warriors is for
for all their or their difficulties in
keeping this
the foot closer to the bottom of the
pedal is that they haven't let this
linger I mean there's no signs that it's
lingered I mean it may come up again in
July when Durant finally decides to
leave if he does but they've been really
good at compartmentalizing their
situation so I think I think curse
frustration with draymond Green is it
draymond greens not playing very well
this year this is not the same draymond
Green of the past
he doesn't sort of help them out with
the occasional three so their spacings a
little bit off and he is you know while
he's still been good defensively he
hasn't been as good as draymond Green
has been in the past and when you put
that together with all the other things
that have sort of beset this otherwise
invulnerable team I think the little
things start to get seen more and when
you're getting your hat blocked at home
by the Phoenix Suns
everything looks bad last one for you
Ray Ratto the Raiders signing of Antonio
Brown is that more for Vegas what do you
make of the Antonio Brown Trent Brown
extravaganza and what Gruden's doing
with Mayock to remake this team in
Gruden's image here I think that was
gonna happen either way I don't know
that it's aimed towards Vegas I mean
that that's a happy ancillary but if you
if you take if you pretend that the
Raiders aren't leaving this is what what
Jon Gruden would do anyway which is
spend year one realizing I hate this
team and I have to get rid of all the
components I can as quickly as possible
yes and he did that now it's time to
rebuild and the Antonio Brown thing is
an outlier anyway because under normal
circumstances a player with his pedigree
would not be on the market even with it
with a franchise like Pittsburgh which
doesn't like to spend money and even
given the fact that he's tested their
patience in about 12 different ways
this is the sort of thing that happened
40 years ago when Al Davis could pick up
guys like Lyle Alzado which is another
team doesn't like a really good player
on his team I'll take them
this is reminiscent of that and that's
why it's so unusual and Bill Barnwell
pointed out that this is such an unusual
development that it almost makes no
sense and there's almost no precedent
for it but if you take the money
component out of it it's very much a
raider deal in that somebody else got
fed up with a really good player I know
we'll take him we don't need to fix him
we don't care if he's fixed we just
wanted to catch footballs for us you
know what I thought the same thing ray
over the last 24 hours
that Al Davis would have loved this guy
who can stretch the field we're gonna go
vertical we're gonna take him he might
have been a guy who created problems in
your spot but he's coming to our spot
it's a silver and black we're committed
to excellence and let's roll that's what
I thought that for sure
he would he would cheerfully have
swindled the Pittsburgh Steelers but I'm
sure wherever he is
it irks him that Jon Gruden did it come
on I think you liked Gruden very much
because green and Hal Davis are a lot
alike they really are I mean just you
know I mean I don't know that that I
mean the thing to remember that Jon
Gruden is there are two voices in his
head at all times
there's the coach who got fed up with
Khalil max he didn't show up for any
OTAs and he traded them for pennies on
the dollar and he got rid of Amari
Cooper because Derek Carr sort of lost
confidence in him he lost confidence in
the team that was just it was spiraling
out of control but Jon Gruden the
general manager and the talent evaluator
would see a guy like Antonio Brown and
go I don't care I want him and the fact
that mike Mayock was able to keep the
price as low as it was by reading the
steelers correctly is i mean that's the
big takeaway here
it's not that the Raiders you know
swindled Pittsburgh although they did
it's that they were ready to do this a
year ago I don't think they would have
but I think now Gruden's torn the team
down basically you know to the studs and
foundation and now it's time to start
rebuilding and Antonio Brown was a gift
from the sky it was it's what we'll see
what happens obviously this year Raymond
you're a treasure thanks for calling in
appreciate it
I didn't call you called me that's true
thank you
thank you for accepting my coffee
appreciate it thank you that's it's
right off the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience